[SQUEAKING]
[PAPERS RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JEREMY KEPNER: All right. Welcome. Great to
see everyone here. We're really excited about
this opportunity. As you know, our AI accelerator
has officially kicked off. All of your teams
are ready to go. And we wanted this to be
an opportunity as a team, come together and
develop some common foundation, some common
technological foundation, some common language
for talking about these very challenging AI
problems.
And so with that, I'll hand it over to Vijay.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: All right.
JEREMY KEPNER: Who will kick off with the first
lecture, which basically provides some overview
AI context for this.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Again, welcome to the class.
We're really looking forward to this. What
we're going to present this morning is really
a lot of overview material, right? Many of
you here know a lot in AI and machine learning.
This is really meant to just level set before
we start the program, before we start these
classes.
So you can see this generic title-- Artificial
Intelligence and Machine Learning. And we're
going to try and cover all of that in about
an hour. So some details might be skipped,
but we'll try and hit some of the salient
features. All of these slides are available
for you to use.
So if you're presenting back to your own teams,
please feel free to pull from these slides.
We've actually gone through-- over some time
putting a good set of survey and overview
slides together. So if any of these are useful
to you, just email us, or we'll make them
available to you. You're more than welcome
to use any and all of these slides if you're
trying to present this back to other people.
So with that, let's begin. So we're going
to do a quick overview of artificial intelligence.
Again, a lot of level setting going on here.
We're going to do a quick, deep dive. These
aren't the deepest of dives, again, given
the amount of time that we have, but just
talk very quickly about supervised, unsupervised,
and reinforcement learning, and then summarize.
And we can certainly stop for questions, philosophical
debates, et cetera, towards the end. We'll
try not to get a lot of the philosophical
debates on camera if we can. All right. So
first question-- what is artificial intelligence?
And this is a question that probably a lot
of you get. And I certainly have received
this from a number of people. And that actually
takes a lot of-- it took us a lot of time
to come up with this.
And so we are very fortunate to have Professor
Winston spend some time with us out at Lincoln
Laboratory. And we actually brainstormed for
a good hour or two, really trying to come
up with what is a good definition for what
we call artificial intelligence. And what
we came up with is that there are two aspects
to artificial intelligence.
First, that we should not confuse with each
other. One is the concept of narrow AI, and
another is a concept of general AI. And sometimes
in conversation, we tend to conflate or mix
the two. So narrow AI, according to our definition,
is the theory and development of computer
systems that perform tasks that augment for
human intelligence, such as perceiving, classifying,
learning, abstracting, reasoning, and/or acting.
Certainly in a lot of the programs that we
work in, we're very focused on narrow AI and
not necessarily the more general AI, which
we define as full autonomy. So that's a very
high-level definition of what we mean by AI.
Now, many of you in the crowd are probably
saying, well, AI has been around for a while.
People have been talking about this for 50,
60-plus years. Why now? What is so special
about it now? Why is this conversation piece
now?
Well, from what we've seen, it really is the
convergence of three different communities
that have come together. The first is the
community on big data. The second is a community
on computing in a lot of computing technologies.
And finally, a lot of research and results
in machine learning algorithms.
The other one I forgot to put is dollar signs
down here. People have basically figured out
how to make money off of selling advertisements,
labeling cat pictures, et cetera. So that's
maybe the hidden-- why now in particular.
But these are the three large technical areas
that have evolved over the past decade or
so to really make AI something we discuss
a lot today.
So when we talk about AI, there are a number
of different pieces which make up an AI system.
And we love the algorithms, people, but there
is a lot more going on outside of that. So
we've spent a significant amount of effort
just trying to figure out what goes into an
AI system.
And this is what we call a canonical architecture.
Very much in line with Lincoln Laboratory
thinking, we like to think of an end to end
pipeline. What are the various components?
And what are the interconnections between
these various components? So within our AI
canonical architecture shown here, we go all
the way from sensors to the end user or missions.
And a lot of the projects that you all are
working on are going to go all the way from
here to there. A lot of our class, however,
for the next few weeks is going to focus on
step one, where a lot of people get stuck.
So we take data that comes in through either
structured or unstructured sources.
These are typically passed into some data
conditioning or data curation step. This data
is through that process, typically converted
into some form of information. That information
is then passed into a series of algorithms,
maybe one or many algorithms. There are lots
of them. There is life beyond neural networks.
Once we pass them through the algorithms,
these typically form. This information is
converted into knowledge. It's typically then
passed into some module that interacts with
the end user, or a human, or the mission.
And that's what we call a human machine teaming
step.
And that finally-- that knowledge with the
human complement becomes insight that can
then be used to execute the mission that the
AI system was created for. All of these components
sit on the bedrock of modern computing. Many
different technologies that make up modern
computing and the system that we're using
today has combination of some of these computing
hardware elements.
And certainly within the context of a lot
of the projects that we are interested in,
all of this also needs to be wrapped in a
layer that we call robust AI, which consists
of explainable artificial intelligence, metrics,
and biased assessment, verification, validation,
security, policy, ethics, safety, and training.
We'll talk very briefly about each of these
pieces in detail in a little bit.
As I mentioned, AI has an extremely rich history.
This is just a very Lincoln and MIT specific
view of the history of artificial intelligence.
But certainly, there has been great work since
the folks of Minsky, Clark, Dineen, Oliver
Selfridge, et cetera, since the '50s. We've
seen a lot of work in the '80s and '90s. And
certainly, recently there has been, again,
a resurgence of AI in our parlance in our
thinking of the way AI works.
So without going into too much detail about
each of these eras and why the winters came
about, et cetera, I think John Launchbury
at DARPA actually put it very well, when he
talked about different waves of AI technology
that have come about. And when he talks about
it, he talks about the three waves of AI or
the four waves of AI. And the first wave,
which you can think of as the first decade
of AI technology, resulted in a lot of reasoning-based
systems, which were based on handcrafted knowledge.
So an example of an output of this would be
an expert system, right? So a lot of work
in that. So if we take the four dimensions
that John Launchbury suggests of the ability
of the system to perceive, learn, abstract,
and reason, these are typically pretty good
at reasoning. Because they encoded human knowledge,
right?
So a human expert sat down and said, what's
going on in the system? And tried to write
a series of rules. So tax software, for example,
does a pretty reasonable job of that where
a chartered accountant or a tax expert sits
down, encodes a series of rules. We have a
question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Yeah. [INAUDIBLE] I just wanted
an example of an expert system from the '50s
to [INAUDIBLE].
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yep. So the question is,
are there examples of expert systems? And
certainly, one would be tax software. My graduate
research was actually an autonomous vehicle.
Some of the early autonomous vehicles used
a form of expert systems where the states
on a finite state machine were maybe handcrafted.
And the transitions between them were designed
that way. There was some machine learning
wrapped around, but expert systems certainly
played a large part in some of the early,
even autonomous vehicle research that went
on. All right. So over time, we were able
to use these expert systems.
And don't get me wrong. These systems are
still extremely valid in cases where you have
limited data availability, limited compute
power, a lot of expert systems still being
used, or in cases where explainability is
a very important factor. You still see expert
systems, because they do have the ability
to explain why they came up. They can typically
point to a set of rules that somebody wrote,
which is usually quite interpretable by a
human.
However, as we were able to collect more data,
we were maybe able to understand a little
bit more about what was the underlying process.
We were able to apply statistical learning.
And this led to the next era or next wave
of AI technologies, which is often called
the learning wave.
And this was really enabled by lots of data-enabled
non-expert systems. So what we mean by that
is we were able to dial back the amount of
expert knowledge that we encoded into the
algorithm, maybe put a higher level of expert
knowledge into that. But usually, then used
data to learn what some of these rules could
be.
An example of that, in case someone wants
to ask, would be in speech processing, for
example. So we were able to say, well, I realized
that speech follows this Gaussian mixture
model. So I can encode that level of statistical
knowledge, but I'm going to let the system
figure out the details of how all that actually
works out.
And there are many other cases. Again, coming
back to some of the research I did on autonomous
vehicles, we were able to maybe use some high-level
expert rules, that here are a set of states
that a car may be in. But I'm going to let
the algorithm actually figure out when these
transitions occur and what constitutes a transition
between different states.
So looking at the four vectors that you could
think about it, these systems had a little
bit more on perception. Obviously, we're doing
a lot more learning. But their ability to
abstract and reason was still pretty low.
And by reasoning, we mean, can you explain?
Can you tell us what's going on when you give
me an output to the result?
The next wave which we're maybe at the beginning
stages of is what we call contextual learning
or contextual adaptation. This is where an
AI system can actually add context into what
it's doing. I'm not sure I have too many examples
of people doing this very well.
I think most of the work today probably falls
into the end stage of the learning wave of
AI. But we're able to combine a bunch of these
learning things to make it look like it's
contextual in nature. But the key concept
over here is being able to have the system
automatically abstract and reason. So the
way that we think about things, right?
So if I see a chair over here and I put a
chair somewhere else, I still know it's a
chair, because I'm using other contexts. Maybe
it's next to a table or stuff like that. Some
early research going on in that area. And
certainly, the next wave of this is what we
call abstraction. And there is very little
work on this, but if we have to think out
in the future.
But this is really the system of the ability
of an AI system to actually abstract information
that it's learning. So instead of learning
that a chair or a table is something with
a leg at the bottom, it learns that a table
is something you put things on and is able
to abstract that information or that knowledge
to any other domain or any other field. Do
we have any questions before I continue from
here? OK, great.
So that's a little bit on the evolution of
AI. The reason we like to go through this
is because there is great work going on in
each of these waves. And nothing that people
are doing in any of these waves is any lesser
or more. It's typically dependent on what
you have at your disposal.
What I like to tell people sometimes is the
way to think about all of this is you have
a couple of dials at your disposal-- turning
dials. The first dial is, how much compute?
Right? How much ability do you have to crunch
data? The second piece is, how much data do
you actually have available? This can be labeled
data in many cases.
And the third dial is, how much knowledge
are you able to embed into an algorithm? In
certain cases where maybe you have very little
computing, very little labeled data availability,
but a lot of expert knowledge or a lot of
ability to encode information into an algorithm,
you might be able to use an expert system,
right? And that's a very good use case for
that.
An example may be on another dimension where
you want to encode very little human knowledge,
but you have a lot of computing and data available,
would be rare neural networks fall in, where
they're essentially learning what the human
knowledge-- what that encoded information
should be.
A lot of statistical techniques also fall
into that camp where maybe you encode a little
bit of information as to what the background
distribution of the process is. But it learns
the details of exactly how that distribution
is modeled, based on the data that it sees.
So you have a lot of different settings that
you can use. And there are a number of different
techniques within the broader AI context that
you can use to achieve your mission. And I'm
sure many of you are going to be doing different
types of algorithms. And a lot of that decision
will be dependent on, well, how much data
was I given? Right? How good is this data
that I'm using? Is there an ability to learn
anything from this?
And if not, you might have to encode some
knowledge of your own into it saying, well,
I know that this process looks like that,
so let me tell the algorithm to not waste
too much time crunching the data to learn
the underlying distribution, which I can tell
you. Why don't you learn the parameters of
the distribution instead? Does that makes
sense? All right.
And as you know, there's just a lot going
on in AI and machine learning. You can't walk
two steps without running into somebody who's
either starting something up, working for
one of these organizations. So it really is
an exciting time to be in the field. All right.
So that's a little bit on the overview, but
let's talk now in a little bit of detail on
what some of the critical components are within
this AI architecture. So one thing that we
like to note-- and there's a reason that as
we've been reaching out to a number of you,
we've been talking about getting data, right?
Work with stakeholders to get your data in
place.
And the reason we talk about that is data
is critical to breakthroughs in AI. A lot
of the press may be on the algorithms and
the algorithms that have been designed. But
really, when we've looked back in history,
we've seen that, well, the availability of
a good canonical data set actually is equally,
if not more critical to a breakthrough in
AI.
So what we've done here is we've just picked
a select number of breakthroughs in AI. Our
definition of a breakthrough in this particular
example is something that made a lot of press
or something that we thought was really cool.
So here are some examples of that in different
years.
And we've talked about the data set, the canonical
data set that maybe led to that breakthrough
or that was cited in that breakthrough as
well as the algorithms that were used in that
breakthrough and when they were first proposed.
This is notional in nature. Clearly, you could
adjust these dates a few years here or there.
But what we really want to get across is that
the average number of years to a breakthrough
from the availability of a cool data set or
a very important, well-structured, well-labeled
data set is much smaller than from the algorithm's
first proposal or when the algorithm first
comes out.
So as you're developing your challenge problems,
as you're developing your interactions with
stakeholders, certainly something to keep
in mind that there's clearly a lot of algorithmic
research that's going to go on. But having
a good, strong, well-labeled, and documented
data set can be equally important. And making
that available to the wider AI community,
the wider AI ecosystem can be very, very valuable
to your work and the work of many other people.
All right.
So back to the AI architecture, we're going
to just go through very briefly-- different
pieces of this architecture. So the first
piece we're going to talk about is data conditioning,
which is converting unstructured and structured
data. Within the structured and unstructured
data, you might have structured sources coming
from sensors, network logs for some of you,
metadata associated with sensors, maybe speech
or other such signals.
There's also a lot of unstructured data. You
think of things that you might collect from
the internet that you might download from,
say, a social media site, maybe reports, other
types of sensors that maybe don't have well--
that don't have the strong structure within
the data set itself.
And typically, this first step, what we call
the data conditioning step, consists of a
number of different elements. You might want
to first figure out where to put this data.
That can often take a lot of time. And there
have been religious wars fought on this topic.
We're here to tell you that you're probably
OK, picking most technologies. But if you
have any questions, feel free to reach out
to me or to others on the team. We have a
lot of opinions on what's the right infrastructure
to solve the problem. Typically, these infrastructure
or databases might provide capabilities such
as indexing, organization, and structure.
Very important in unstructured data to convert
it into some format that you can do things
with.
They may allow you to connect to them using
domain specific languages. So it's converting
it into a language that maybe you're used
to talking. They can provide high-performance
data access and in many cases, a declarative
interface. Because maybe you don't really
care about how the data is being accessed.
You want to just say select the data, give
it to me. And then move forward from there.
Another important part of the data conditioning
step is data curation. This unfortunately
will probably take you a very long time. And
it requires a lot of knowledge of the data
itself, what you want to do with the data,
and how you receive the data.
But what you might do in the data curation
step is perform some unsupervised learning,
maybe reduce the dimensionality of your problem.
You might do some clustering or pattern recognition
to maybe remove certain pieces of your data
or to highlight certain pieces of the data
that look important.
You might do some outlier detection. You might
highlight missing values. There's just dot,
dot, dot, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
A lot goes on in the data curation step. We
could certainly spend hours just talking about
that. And the final thing, especially within
the context of supervised machine learning,
but even in the world of unsupervised learning
would be spending some time on data labeling,
right?
So this is taking data that you've received,
typically doing an initial data exploration.
Could be as simple as opening it up in Excel
to see what the different columns and rows
look like if that's a suitable place to open
it up. You might look for highlight, missing,
or incomplete data, just from your initial
data exploration.
You might be able to go back to the data provider
or to the sensor and say, can you reorient
the sensors or recapture the data? I noticed
that every time you've measured this particular
quantity, it always shows up as 3. I can't
imagine that that's correct. Can you go back
and tell me if that sensor is actually working?
Or is it actually 3? In which case, you might
want to know that.
And you might look for errors, biases, and
collection, of course, on top of the actual
labeling process that you're doing to highlight
phenomenology within the data that you'd like
to then look for through your machine learning
algorithms. I'll pause for a second. Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a quick question.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the ratio that you see between
structured data and unstructured data?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question is, what's
the ratio we see between structured and unstructured
data? That's a great question. So the ratio
in terms of the volume or the ratio in terms
of what you can do with it? Because those
are actually almost the opposite.
So, again, I'm talking about a few data sets
that I'm very familiar with. The unstructured
data can often be 90% of the volume. And maybe
the 10% is the metadata associated with the
unstructured data. Most of the value, however,
comes from the structured data where people
really analyze the crap out of these structured
data, because they know how to.
There is certainly a lot of potential within
the unstructured data. So when we talk to
people, that's why we talk a lot about infrastructure
and databases as being an important first
step. Because if you can just take the unstructured
data and put it into a structured or semi-structured
form, that itself can provide a lot of value.
Because very often in problems that we see,
the 90% volume of data is largely untapped.
Because people don't know how to get into
it, or don't know what to do with it, or it's
not in a form that you can really deal with.
So I think next class, we're going to be talking
to you about how to organize your data, strategies
for organizing data that can get you a lot
more value out of the unstructured data. Does
that answer your question? Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question is when you
apply AI or machine learning techniques to
a problem domain, is it typically a single
modality or multiple modalities? I'd say the
answer is both. Certainly, there's a lot of
research. And back there, we have Matthew,
who's actually doing research on that right
now on how to fuse multiple modalities of
data.
I know a lot of projects that are being discussed
here are certainly looking at multiple modalities.
If I had to say as of today, a lot of the
work that's out there-- the published work
may be focused on a single modality. But that's
not to say-- I mean, I think there is a lot
of value on multiple modalities. But the challenge
still comes up on, how do you integrate this
data, especially if they're collected from
different systems? Yep?
AUDIENCE: Just on the structure versus unstructured.
So it's not really my area, but I am surprised
to see speech in the structured [INAUDIBLE].
And I wonder. Is that just because the technologies
that can force the [INAUDIBLE] and all of
this data conditioning are mature enough that
you can basically treat it [INAUDIBLE]?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question is, why would
speech or something else like that fall into
structured versus unstructured? And you're
absolutely right. I think when we pick speech--
and I'm sure there are others in the room
that might disagree with that and might stick
it over here.
When we look at the type of acquisition processes
that are used, the software that's used, they
typically come out with some known metadata.
They follow a certain pattern that we can
then use, right? There is a clear range to
where there is-- the frequency to which the
data is collected. And that's why we stuck
it in the structured data type.
Of course, if you're collecting data out in
the field without that, you could probably
stick it into the unstructured world as well.
But that's probably a good example of something
that can fall in between the two places. OK.
All right. Now, for the part everyone's really
interested in-- machine learning, right?
So, all right, you got through the boring
data conditioning stuff, which will take you
a couple of years or something like that.
Nothing serious. And now, you're ready to
do the machine learning. And now, you're given
a choice. Well, which algorithm do you use?
Neural networks, you might say, right?
There is a lot more, though, beyond the neural
network world. So there is numerous taxonomies.
I'm going to give you two of them today for
how you describe machine learning algorithms.
One that's really an interesting way is from
Pedro Domingos at the University of Washington
in which he says that there are five tribes
of machine learning.
So there are the symbolists, which an example
of that would be expert systems. There are
the Bayesian tribes, which an example of an
algorithm within that might be naive Bayes.
There are the analogizers, which an example
of that would be a support vector machine
and the connectionists, an example of which
would be deep neural networks. And evolutionary
is an example of that which might be genetic
programming.
What really I'm trying to get across-- I'm
sure the author is trying to get across here
is that lots and lots of different algorithms.
Each have their relative merits and relative
strengths. Apply the right one for your application.
Apply the right one for-- again, given these
dials that I talked about earlier, the amount
of computing that you have available, the
amount of data that you have available, and
the amount of expert knowledge that you're
able to encode into your algorithm that you
think is generalizable enough.
If we actually talk about-- this is a very
useful chart I found in describing to folks
that are not familiar with AI that might say,
wasn't AI just neural networks? And neural
networks are a part of AI, but not necessarily
all of it. So if we think of the big circle
is the broad field of artificial intelligence,
within that is the world of machine learning.
Within machine learning are connectionists
or neural networks that fall into a small
camp within that. And deep neural networks
is a part of neural network. So can anyone
maybe give me an example-- although, I've
said it numerous times-- of something that
might fall out of machine learning, but into
artificial intelligence from an algorithmic
point of view? Yes?
AUDIENCE: Graph search.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Graph search could be an
example. I would maybe stick that into some
of the connectionists, however.
AUDIENCE: Expert systems.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yes, exactly. So expert systems--
it's the one that comes to my mind. Or knowledge-based
systems are an example of maybe something
that fall outside of the realm of machine
learning, again in the very strict sense,
but maybe within the realm of artificial intelligence
from an algorithmic point of view.
OK, so that's a little bit on the algorithms.
Next, let's talk about some of the modern
computing engines that are out there. I mentioned
that data compute as well as algorithms have
been key drivers to the resurgence of AI over
the past few years. What are some of these
computing technologies, for example? So clearly,
CPUs and GPUs. They're very popular computing
platforms. Lots of software written to work
with these computing platforms.
But what we're seeing now is that with the
end of Moore's Law and a lot more performance
engineering going on, we're seeing a lot more
work, research, and hardware architectures
that are custom in nature. And custom architectures
are almost the new commercial off-the-shelf
solutions that are out there.
So an example of a custom architecture could
be Google's Tensor Processing Unit, or TPU.
There is some very exciting research going
on in the world of neuromorphic computing.
I'm happy to chat with you all later if you're
interested to know what's going on in that
area and maybe our role in some of that work.
And there is just some stuff that we would
still call custom. These are still people
deciding, designing, basically looking at
an algorithm saying, OK, here's the data layout.
Here is the movement of data or information
within this algorithm. Let's create a custom
processor that does that. An example of that
could be the graph processor, which is being
developed at Lincoln Laboratory.
And obviously, no slide on computing architectures
or computing technologies would be complete
without mentioning the word quantum in it.
There is some early results on solving linear
system of equations. But I think applied to
AI, it's still unsure, or unknown, or unproven
where quantum may play a part. But certainly,
a technology that all of us, I'm sure, have
heard of, or continue to track, or just interested
in seeing where that goes to.
So within the first few, however, these are
all products that you can buy today. You can
go out to your favorite-- your computing store
and just purchase these off-the-shelf solutions.
A lot of software has been written to work
with these different technologies. And it's
a really nice time to be involved. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you give a brief just concept
of what is attached to the [INAUDIBLE]? I
see [INAUDIBLE], but I don't really have a
high-level concept of why I should associate
with that.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: OK, so the question is, what
should I think about when I'm thinking about
neuromorphic? So there's a few features which
I say fall into the camp of what people are
calling neuromorphic computing. One is what
they're calling a brain inspired architecture,
which often means its clockless.
So you typically have some-- so a lot of these
technologies have clocked movement of information.
These might be clockless in nature. They typically
sit on top of different types of memory architectures.
And I'm trying to think of what would be another
parameter that would be very useful. I can
probably send you a couple things that help
highlight that. I certainly wouldn't call
myself an expert in this area.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: But, yeah. I think the term
that's used is it's supposed to mimic the
brain in the way that the computing architecture
actually performs or functions. So lots of
research as well. And this is work that we've
done here at the lab on actually trying to
map the performance of these different processors
and how they perform for different types of
functions.
So what we're doing here is basically looking
at the power on the x-axis. And the y-axis
is the peak performance in giga operations
per second. Different types of precision are
noted over there by the different shapes of
the boxes and then different form factors.
And the idea here is basically to say there's
so much going on in the world of computing.
How can we compare them? They all have their
own individual areas where they're strong.
So one can't come up and say, well, the GPU
is better than the CPU. Well, it depends on
what you're trying to do and what your goals
of the operation are.
So some of the key lines to note here is that
there seems to be a lot of existing systems
on this 100 giga operations per watt on this
line over here, this dash line. Some of the
newer offerings maybe fit into the 1 tera
op per watt. And some of the research chips
like IBM's TrueNorth or Intel's Arria fall
into just a bit under the 10 tera operations
per watt line that we see there.
But depending on the type of application,
you may be OK with a certain amount of peak
power. So if you're looking at embedded applications,
you're probably somewhere over here, right?
If you're trying to get something that's on
a little drone or something like that, you
might want to go here. And if you have a data
center, you're probably OK with that type
of power utilization or peak power utilization.
But you do need the performance that goes
along with that.
So I'd say the most important parts to look
at are essentially these different lines.
Those are the trajectories for maybe some
of the existing systems, all the way up to
some of the more research oriented processors
out there. OK? All right.
So we talked about modern computing. Let's
talk a little bit about the robust AI side
of things. And the basic idea between robust
AI is that it's extremely important. And the
reason that it's important is that the consequence
of actions on certain applications of AI can
be quite high.
So what we've done here is think about, where
are the places that maybe humans and machines
have their relative strength? So on the x-axis,
we're talking about the consequence of action.
So this could be, does somebody get hurt if
the system doesn't do the right thing? All
the way down to, no worries if the system
doesn't do the right thing, which could be
maybe some of the labeling of images that
we see online, might fall into this category.
I'm sure people disagree with me on that.
But maybe a lot of national security applications.
Health applications certainly fall into the
area of high consequence of action. If you
give someone the wrong treatment, that's a
deal. And then on the y-axis, we're talking
about the confidence level in the machine
making the decision. So how much confidence
do we have in the system that's actually making
the decision?
In certain cases, we might have very high
confidence in the system that's making a decision.
And obviously in certain cases, we do not
have much confidence in the system making
the decision. So in areas where you have a
low consequence of action, maybe high confidence
level in the machine making the decision,
we might say those are best matched to machines.
Those are good candidates for automation.
On the contrary, there might be areas where
that consequence of action is very high. And
we have very little confidence in the system
that's making the decision, probably an area
we want humans to be intricately, if not solely
or involved or responsible. And the area in
between is where machines might be augmenting
humans.
Does anybody want to venture maybe a couple
of examples-- help come up with a couple of
examples here that we might put into each
of these categories? So maybe what's a good
problem that you can think of that might be
best matched to machines, beyond labeling
images for advertisements?
AUDIENCE: Assembly lines.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Assembly lines? Yep, that's
a good example. I'm thinking within spam filtering,
could be another example where-- I mean, there
is some machine augmenting human. It does
send you an email saying this is spam. Are
you sure? But for the most part, it's largely
automated.
I'd say a lot of the work that many of us
are probably doing falls into this category,
maybe on different sides of the spectrum,
but of where machines are augmenting humans.
So the system can be providing data back to
a human that can then select. It might filter
information out for humans that then the humans
can then go ahead and say, OK, well, instead
of looking at a thousand documents, I can
only look at 10, which is much better.
And then there's obviously certain-- probably
we want humans to be heavily involved with
any kinetic-- anything that involves life
or death-- we probably want. And there are
probably legal reasons, also, that we want
humans involved with things like that.
One of the examples that we often get which
is autonomous vehicles-- and it's always a
little confusing where autonomous vehicles
fall into this. Certainly, the consequence
of action of a mistake in an autonomous vehicle
can be pretty high.
And as of today, the confidence and the decision-making
is medium at best. But people still seem to
somehow be OK with fully automating. That
just shows how terrible Boston roads or driving
in general is, that we're like, I'm not really
sure if this thing will kill me or not, but
totally worth trying it out.
AUDIENCE: Do you think the trend in this chart
is to slowly expand the yellow out?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yes, I'd say-- the question
is, is the yellow expanding? I think so. One
could make the argument that, is it shifting
that direction? Are we finding areas where--
and I think that's maybe the direction. We
are probably looking at automating certain
things a little bit more as confidence in
decision-making goes up.
So you might think about this frontier moving
down so that maybe the green expanding slightly
and the yellow taking over a little bit of
the red. There might be some places where
over time, we're more open to the machine
making a decision and the human having a largely
supervisory role, which I would put right
at this frontier between the yellow and the
red.
AUDIENCE: Again, I guess it depends on what
augmenting means. But I guess [INAUDIBLE]
is truly red without any-- even cognitive
augmenting.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: I can think of some examples,
but maybe I'll share it with you later. So
certainly, a robust artificial intelligence
plays a very important part in the development
and deployment of AI systems. I won't go through
the details of each of these.
I'm sure many of you are very familiar with
it. And I know a few of you are far more knowledgeable
about this, maybe than I am. But some of the
key features would be explainable AI, which
is a system being able to describe what it's
doing in an interpretable fashion.
Metrics-- so being able to provide the right
metric if you want to go beyond accuracy or
performance. Validation and verification--
there might be cases where you're not really
concerned about the explainability, but you
just want to know that when I pass an input,
I get a known output out of it. And is there
a way to confirm that I'm able to do that?
Another could be on security. So an example
of this-- or not having security would be
counter AI, right? So when we talk about security
within the context of robust AI, it's almost
like the cryptographic way of thinking about
it, which is, can I protect the confidentiality,
integrity, and availability of my algorithm,
the data sets, the outputs, the weights, the
biases, et cetera?
And finally, a lot of significant importance
is policy, ethics, safety, and training. This
is actually very important in some of those
applications where in the previous slide,
we had the yellow and the red where humans
and machines augmenting humans, where that
falls.
A lot of that might be governed by policy,
ethics, safety, and training, which is some
of the examples that I can think of, where
there are policy reasons that make it that
only a human can be involved with this, maybe
with minimal input from a system. OK.
And the final component of our AI architecture--
we've gone through conditioning, algorithms,
computing, robust AI-- is human machine teaming.
And I think what we want to get across with
human machine teaming-- that is it really
depends on the application and what you're
trying to do. But it is important to think
about the human and the machine working together.
And there is a spectrum of where the machine
will largely-- will play a large part and
the human largely supervisory or to where
the human plays a large part and the machine
is very targeted in what you do with the machine
or the AI of the system.
But a couple of ways to think about it would
be-- of course, we talked about the confidence
level versus consequence of actions, but also,
the scale versus application complexity. So
on the top chart over there, we have on the
x-axis is the application complexities. How
complex is this application? And on the y-axis
is the scale. How many times do you need to
keep doing this thing?
Places that machines might be more effective
than humans are where we have low application
complexity, but very, very high skill. So
again, spam filtering falls into this. The
complexity of spam filtering has gone up over
time, but is something that is reasonable
within systems. But the scale is very high,
that we just don't want a human being involved
with that process.
And on the other end of the spectrum is where
you have very high application complexity
that'll only happen a couple of times. So
this could be, say, reviewing a situation.
Maybe a company is trying to make an acquisition.
It's not going to happen over and over.
So you might have a human involved with that,
that goes through a lot of that. Maybe they
target the system to go look for specific
pieces of information. But really, it's the
human that might be more effective in that,
especially given that the situation would
change over and over. All right.
So with that, we're going do take a quick
tour of the world of machine learning. I'll
stop there for a second. Any questions? OK.
All right. So what is machine learning? Always
a good place to start. It's the study of algorithms
to improve their performance at some task
with experience. In this context, experience
is data.
And they typically do this by optimizing based
on some performance criteria that uses example
data or past experience. So in the world of
supervised learning, that could be the example
data. Or past experience could be the correct
label, given an input data set or input data
point.
Machine learning is a combination of techniques
from statistics, computer, and computer science
communities. And it's the idea of getting
computers to program themselves. Common tasks
within the world of machine learning could
be things like classification, regression,
prediction, clustering, et cetera.
For those who are maybe making the shift to
machine learning from traditional programming,
I found this, again, from Pedro Domingos to
be a very useful way of describing it to people.
So in traditional programming, you have a
data set. You write a program, which would
be if you see this, do that. When you see
this, do that. For this many instances, do
the following thing on it and then write an
output out, right?
So you input a data into the program into
a computer, and the computer produces an output
where it says, OK, I've applied this program
on that data. And this gives me the output.
Machine learning is a very different way of
thinking about it in which you're almost inputting
the data as well as the output.
So in this case, the data could be unlabeled
images. The output could be the labels associated
with those images. And you tell the computer,
figure out what the program would look like.
And this is a slightly different way of thinking
about machine learning versus traditional
programming.
What are some of these programs or algorithms
that the computer might use to figure it out?
So within the large realm of machine learning,
we have supervised, unsupervised reinforcement
learning. What we have in the brackets is
essentially what you're providing in the world.
In the case of supervised learning, you're
providing labels, which is the correct label
associated with an input feature or with an
input data set or data point. In unsupervised
learning, you typically have no labels, but
also are limited by what the algorithm itself
can do.
And in the world of reinforcement learning,
instead of a label per data point, you're
providing the reward information to the system
that says if you're doing more-- if you're
doing the right thing, I'm going to give you
some points. If you're doing the wrong thing,
I'm going to take away some points-- very
useful in very complex applications where
you can't really figure out the labels associated
with each data point.
Within the world of supervised learning, the
typical tasks that people have-- and I should
note before I go through this. There's a lot
of overlap between all of these different
pieces. So this is a high-level view. But
we can certainly argue about the specific
positioning of everything. I'm sure we can.
So within supervised learning, you can fall
into classification regression. Unsupervised
learning is typically clustering dimensionality
reduction. And within these, there are different
algorithms that fall into place. So examples
could be things like neural nets that cover
all of these spaces.
You got-- just take regression, PCA, which
might fall into dimensionality reduction,
lots and lots of different techniques and
also some in the reinforcement learning world.
And there's just more and more and more. If
you open up a survey of machine learning,
it'll give you even more than all of these
techniques over here.
And the thing to remember when you're using
machine learning is that there are some common
pitfalls that you can fall into. An example
of that would be overfitting versus underfitting
where you come up with this awesome model
that does really, really well on your training
data.
You apply it to your test data, and you get
terrible results. You might have done a really
good job learning the training data, but not
necessarily learning-- being able to generalize
beyond that. Sometimes it could be just the
algorithm itself is unable to correctly model
the behavior that's exhibited by the training
and test data.
I won't go through each of these again, but
there might just be bad, noisy, missing data.
That certainly happens where you end up with
an algorithm with terrible results. And you
look at it and you're like, well, why is that?
And you actually look at the data that you
did. And it was incorrect, that there was
just missing features. Or it was noisy in
nature, such that the actual phenomenology
that you were trying to look for was hidden
within the noise.
You might have picked the wrong model. You
might have used a linear model in a non-linear
case where the phenomenology you're trying
to describe is non-linear in nature, but maybe
you've used a linear model. You've not done
a good job of separating training versus testing
data, et cetera, et cetera.
So we'll just take a quick view into each
of these different learning paradigms. So
the first is on supervised learning. And you
basically start with label data or what we
call-- it was often referred to as ground
truth. And you build a model that predicts
labels, given new pieces of data.
And you have two general goals. One is in
regression, which is to predict some continuous
variable or a classification, which is to
predict a class or label. So if we look at
this, the diagram on the right, we have training
data that we provide, which is data and labels.
That goes into a trained model. That's typically
an iterative process where we find out, well,
did we do a good job? That is now called a
supervised learning model that we then apply
new data, or test data, or unseen data and
look at the predicted labels.
Typically, when you are designing an algorithm
like this, you'd separate out. You'd take
your training data. You'd remove a small portion
of it that you do know the labels for. That's
your test data over here. And then you run
that. And you can see, well, is it working
well or not?
And most of these algorithms have a training
step that forms a model. So when we talk about
machine learning in both the supervised and
unsupervised sense, we'll often talk about
training the model, which is this process,
and then inference, which is the second step,
which is where you apply unseen data. So this
is the trained model in deployment or in the
field. It's performing inference at that point.
Of course, no class these days on machine
learning and AI could go without talking about
neural networks. And as I mentioned, neural
networks do form a very important part of
machine learning. And they certainly are an
algorithm that many of you, I'm sure, are
familiar with. And they fall well within the
supervised and unsupervised. And they've been
used for so many different applications at
this point.
So what's a neural network? A computing system
inspired by biological networks. And the system
essentially learns by repetitive training
to do tasks based on examples. Much of the
work that we've seen is typically it being
applied to supervised learning, though I'll
mention some that we are doing, some research
and actually applying it for unsupervised
learning as well. And they're quite powerful.
The components of a neural network include
inputs, layers, outputs, and weights. So these
are often the terms that someone will use.
And a deep neural network has lots of hidden
layers. Does anyone here have a better definition
for what deep neural network means beyond
lots? I've heard definitions anywhere, 3 and
above. Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] deep neural network
will occur at any recurrent networks. Because
that has more than one layer, but not necessarily
more than one layer after you have actually
written the code for it.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: OK, so one definition here
for deep is-- and this is-- anyone have a
better-- no. So the one to beat right now
is-- a feature of a deep neural network could
be recurrence within the network architecture,
which implies that there is some depth to
the overall network. So above 3 with recurrence--
deep. All right.
Lots of variance within the supervised world
of neural networks, such as convolutional
neural networks, recursive neural networks,
deep belief networks. One, I think, in my
opinion-- again, since you've all asked me
to opine here. I know you've not, but I think
a reason that these are so popular these days
is there's so many tools out there that are
very easy to use.
You can just go online and within about five
minutes, write your first neural network.
Try writing a hidden mark-off model that quickly.
Maybe there are people who can, but in general.
So what are the features of a deep neural
network? So you have some input features.
You have weights, which are essentially associated
with each line over here, as well as biases
for each of the layers that govern the interaction
between the layers and then an output layer.
So these input features can often be combined
to each other. So these feature vectors that
are coming in can often be combined. Think
Jeremy we'll talk a little bit about how the
matrix view of all of this.
But you can think of it as if your-- an example
could be if you have an image, it could be
the RGB pixel values of each pixel in that
image, could be the input feature. So you
could have large numbers of input features.
If you have a time series signal, it could
be the amplitude or the magnitude at a particular
frequency or at a particular step.
There's often a combination of features that
you might do. So in addition to the pixel
intensities for an image, you might also then
combine the spatial distance between two pixels.
Or its position within the image may also
be another input feature. And you can really
go hog wild over here, just trying to come
up with new features.
And there's a lot of research just in that
area, which is I take a data set that everyone
knows. And I'm just going to spend a lot of
time doing feature engineering, which is coming
up with, well, what is the right way to do
the features? So coming back to an earlier
question, this is an area where people are
often looking at supplementing maybe a given
data set with additional data.
And then fusing those two pieces together,
for example, could be audio and text together
as input features to a network, that you can
then learn that might do a better job. But
all of this is governed by this really, really
simple, but powerful equation, which is that
the output at the i plus 1th layer is given
by some non-linear function of the weights
multiplied by the inputs from the previous
step, plus some bias term then.
And when you're learning-- when you're training
a machine learning model, you're essentially
trying to figure out what the Ws are and what
the Bs are. That's really what a model is
defined as. So if we zoom into one of these
pieces, it's actually pretty straightforward
what's going on over here.
So you have your inputs that are coming from
the previous layers, so this could be your
Y sub i. Here are the different weights, so
W1, W2, W3. These are the connections or the
weights going into a neuron or a node. And
you're performing some function on these inputs.
And that function is referred to as an activation
function.
So let's just take an example where we have
some actual numbers. Maybe I've gone through.
I've trained my models. I figured out that
just for this one dot in that big network
that we saw earlier, that my weights are 2.7,
8.6, and 0.002. My inputs from the previous
layer is maybe -0.06, 2.5, 1.4.
And all I'm doing is coming up with this x,
which is -0.06 multiplied by 2.7, plus 2.5,
times 8.6, plus 1.4 times that. That gives
me some number-- 21.34. I apply my non-linear
function, which in this case is a sigmoid
governed by that equation at the top right.
And I say f of 21.34, so somewhere way over
there is approximately 1, right? So this--
probably a little less than 1, but approximately
1 for the purpose of this.
And you just do that over and over. So really,
a neural network-- I think the power of a
neural network is it allows you to encode
a lot less information than many of the other
machine learning algorithms out there at the
cost, typically, of a lot more data being
used and a lot more computing being used.
But for many people, that's perfectly fine,
right?
But it does take-- it's just over and over,
back and forth, back and forth, back and forth
to come up with, what's the right Ws in order
for this to give me a result that looks reasonable?
Lots of work going on and just deciding the
right activation function.
I showed you a sigmoid over there. We do a
lot of work with ReLU units. The choices--
there are certain applications-- certain,
I should say, domains or applications where
people have found that a particular activation
function tends to work well.
But that choice is something I leave to domain
experts to maybe look at their problem and
figure out what are the relative advantages.
Each of these have their own advantages. I
know, for example, one of the big advantages
of rectified linear unit is that since you're
not limiting yourself between a -0 and 1 range,
you don't have to do that. You don't run into
a problem of vanishing gradients. That doesn't
mean much for people. That's OK. We're not
going to spend too much time talking about
that anyhow.
AUDIENCE: Vijay?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So in general, [INAUDIBLE].
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question is picking
the activation functions, picking the number
of layers. We'll talk about that in a couple
of slides. But there is a lot of art. Trial
and error-- yes, but also, we'll call it art
as well that's involved with coming up with
that.
A lot of what happens in practice, however,
is you find an application area, which looks
very similar to the problem that you are trying
to solve. And you might borrow the architecture
from there and use that as a starting point
in coming up with where you start. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you aware of any research of
some type of parameterizing the activation
function and then trying to learn the activation
function?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: I'm sure people are doing
it. I'm personally not familiar with that
research. I don't if anyone else in the room
has-- yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] DARPA D3M program, so
data-driven machine learning. You're trying
to learn both the architecture of the network
and the activation function and therefore
all the other attributes. Because you're trying
to just go from data set to machine learning
system with no human intervention.
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question was, is there
any research into parameterizing the activation
function? So I guess the model as a whole.
So, yeah, there is. And one of the responses
was that there is a program run by DARPA,
which is the D3M program, which is really
looking at, can you go from data to result
with no or almost no human intervention?
I'm not familiar with activation function
parameterization. But certainly, network model
parameterization is absolutely there. So people
who are running optimization models to basically
look for-- I have this particular set of resources.
What is the best model architecture that fits
into that?
Maybe I want to deploy this on a really tiny
processor that only gives me 16 megabytes
of memory. I want to make sure that my model
and data can fit on that. Can you find what
would be the ideal model for that? So that's
absolutely something that people are doing
right now. But I'm not sure if people are
trying to come up with, I guess, brand new
activation functions. All right.
So lots of stuff in the neural network landscape.
And as I mentioned earlier, neural network
training is essentially adjusting weights
until the function represented by the neural
network essentially does what you would like
it to do. And the key idea here is to iteratively
adjust weights to reduce the error.
So what you do is you take some random instantiation
of your neural network or maybe based on another
domain or another problem. You might borrow
that. And you start there. And then you pass
a data set in. You look at the output and
you say, that's not right. What went wrong
over here?
And you go back and adjust things and do that
again, and again, and again, and again, and
again, over and over, until you get something
that looks reasonable. That's really what's
going on over there. And so real neural networks
can have thousands of input, data points--
hundreds of layers, and millions to billions
of weight changes per iteration. Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what you're talking about is
[INAUDIBLE] adjustment [INAUDIBLE]. Do you
know of any [INAUDIBLE] this process?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: Yes, there's a lot of work
being done to parallelize this--
AUDIENCE: Like, for--
VIJAY GADEPALLY: --and by default.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So the question is when--
as I just described it right now, it's a serial
process where I pass one data point in. It
goes all the way to the end. It says, oh,
this is the output-- goes back and adjusts.
Are there techniques that people are doing
to do this in a distributed fashion? And the
answer to that is a strong yes. It's a very
active area in especially high-performance
computing and machine learning.
We might talk about this in-- are we talking
about this on day three? We might talk a little
bit about it. But there is model parallelism,
which is I have the model itself distributed
across multiple pieces. And I want to adjust
different pieces of the model at the same
time. There's research and lots of results.
I think we might even have some examples that
people are doing with that.
AUDIENCE: Have you got some examples on the
[INAUDIBLE] approach, the [INAUDIBLE] approach?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: A little bit earlier.
AUDIENCE: Communication [INAUDIBLE].
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So there are many different
ways to parallelize it. One would be data
parallelism, which is I take my big data set
or big data point, and I distribute that across
my different nodes. And each one independently
learns a model that works well. And then I
do some synchronization across these different
pieces.
There are also techniques where you have--
the model itself may be too big to sit on
a single node or a single processing element.
And you might have to distribute that. So,
yes, a lot of very interesting research going
on in that area. And by default, when you
do run things, they are running in parallel,
just even on your GPU. They're using multiple
cores at once. So there is some level of--
within the node itself, parallelism that runs
by default on most machine learning software.
So inferences-- I mentioned is just using
the trained model again. And the power of
neural networks really falls within their
non-linearity. So you have that non-linear
F function that you're applying over and over
and over across your layers. And this crudely
drawn diagram on my iPad-- this is not clear
at all.
If you had Xs and Os, right? It reminds me
of a song. And you have features over here.
And you're trying to basically classify it.
Which is an X? And which is an O? A linear
classifier could do a pretty good job in this
type of situation. And you could apply a neural
network to this, but maybe it's overkill in
that type of situation.
But in some feature space, if this is how
your Xs and Os are divided amongst each other
and you're trying to come up with the right
label, one thing I might suggest is maybe
find another feature space that you could
maybe get a better separation between the
two. Or a technique like a neural network
might do a very good job. Or any of these
non-linear machine learning techniques might
do a very good job for looking for these really
complex decision boundaries that are out there.
All right.
So you mentioned earlier when you're designing
a neural network, what do you have to do?
What are the different choices, et cetera?
There is a lot going on here. So you have
to pick the depth, the number of layers, the
inputs, and what the inputs are, the type
of network that you're using, the types of
layers, the training algorithm and metrics
that you're using to assess the performance
of this neural network.
The good thing, however, is it so expensive
to train a neural network, that you largely
are not making these decisions in many cases.
You just pick up what somebody else has done,
and you start from there, and then you start.
That might be-- I don't know if that's a good
or a bad thing. But that's often a way in
practice that people end up doing this.
But there is some theory on the general approach.
I think in this short amount of time, which
I'm already over, we won't be able to get
into it. But I'm happy to-- actually, these
slides have backups on them. So when I share
them with you, they do have a lot more detail
on each of these different pieces. All right.
Very quickly, we'll talk about unsupervised
learning. And the basic idea is the task of
describing a hidden structure from unlabeled
data. So in contrast to supervised learning,
we are not providing labels. We're just giving
the algorithm a data set and saying, tell
me something cool that's going on over here.
Now, clearly, you can't label the data if
you do that. But what you can do is maybe
look for clusters or look for dimensions or
pieces of the data that are unimportant or
extraneous. So if we observe certain features,
we would like to observe the patterns amongst
these features.
And the typical tasks that one would do in
unsupervised learning is clustering and data
projection, or data pre-processing, or dimensionality
reduction. And the goal is to discover interesting
things about the data set, such as subgroups,
patterns, clusters, et cetera.
In unsupervised learning-- one of the difficulties
in supervised learning-- we know, right? We
have an input. We have a label. And we're
like, OK, if that input-- if my algorithm
doesn't give me the label, bad. Go retrain.
Or I know what-- I can go back, use that as
my performance metric.
On unsupervised learning, there is no simple
goal such as maximizing a certain probability
for the algorithm. Some of that is going to
be something that you have to work on, is
at the interclass or intraclass distance that
I'm most having that separation. Is that going
to be my performance metric? Is it the number
of clusters that I'm creating? Is that the
number of-- is that the metric that I'm using?
But it is very popular, because it works on
unlabeled data. And I'm sure many of us work
on data sets, which are just too large or
too difficult to sit and label. An example
that comes to my mind, certainly, is in the
world of cybersecurity where you're collecting
billions and billions of networked packets.
And you're trying to look for an almost behavior.
You're not going to go through and look at
each pack and be like, bad, good, what it
is. But you might use an unsupervised technique
to maybe extract out some of the relevant
pieces, then use a supervised-- then go through
the trouble of labeling that data, and then
pass that on to a supervised learning technique.
And I'm happy to share some research that
we've been doing on that front.
Some common techniques are within clustering
and data projection. Clustering is the basic
idea that we want to group objects or sets
of features, such that objects in the same
cluster are more similar to those of another
cluster. And what you typically do for that
is you put your data in some feature space,
and you try to maximize some intracluster
measure, which is basically saying, I want
the points within my cluster to be closer
than anything outside of my cluster, right?
So that's a metric. And you iteratively move
the membership from each. You set a number
of clusters, saying, I need five clusters.
It'll randomly assign things. And it'll keep
adjusting the membership of a particular data
point within a cluster, based on a metric
such as the squared error.
So in this example, we might say that, OK,
these are three clusters that I get out of
it. Dimensionality reduction is the idea of
reducing the number of random variables under
consideration. Very often, you'll collect
a data set that has hundreds to thousands
of different features.
Maybe some of these features are not that
important. Maybe they're unchanging. Or even
if they are changing, it's not by much. And
so maybe you want to remove them from consideration.
That's when you use a technique like dimensionality
reduction. And this is really, really important
when you're doing feature selection and feature
extraction in your real data sets. And you
might also use it for other techniques, such
as compression or visualization.
So if you want to show things on Excel, showing
a thousand dimensional object may be difficult.
You might try to project it down to the two
or three dimensions that are easiest to visualize.
And of course, you can use neural networks
for unsupervised learning as well. Surprise,
surprise.
So as much as a lot of the press you've seen
has been on things like image classification
using nice labeled data sets, there's a lot
of work where you can apply it in an unsupervised
case. And these are largely used to find better
representations for data, such as clustering
and dimensionality reduction. And they're
really powerful because of their non-linear
capabilities.
So one example-- I won't spend way too much
time on this-- is an autoencoder. And the
basic idea behind an autoencoder is you're
trying to find some compressed representation
for data. And the way we do this is by changing
the metric that we use to say that the system
has done a good job.
And the metric is basically-- if I have a
set of input features that I'm passing in,
I would like to do the best job in reconstructing
that input at my output. And what I do is
I squeeze it through a smaller number of layers,
which forms this compressed representation
for my data set.
And so the idea here is, how can I pass my
inputs through this narrow waste to come up
with a reconstructed input that's very similar
to my original input? And so my metric in
this particular case is essentially the difference
between the reconstructed input or the output
and the input. And the compressed representation--
you can think of as the reduced dimensionality
version of my problem.
We've also done some work on replicator networks,
which are also really, really cool. Happy
to chat about that as well. And finally, we
have to talk very briefly on reinforcement
learning. And the basic-- again, at a very
high level, the reason reinforcement learning
is fundamentally different than supervised
or unsupervised learning is that you're not
passing in a label associated with an input
feature.
So there is no supervisor or a person that
can label it, but just a reward signal. And
the feedback is often delayed. And time is
important, so it steps through a process.
And the agent's actions often change the input
data that it receives. So just to maybe--
in the interest of time, just to give you
examples of where reinforcement learning could
work and why you would use a technique like
reinforcement learning.
So flying stunt maneuvers in a helicopter.
So if your helicopter is straight, you say
keep doing more of whatever you're doing to
keep it there. If the helicopter tips over,
you say stop doing whatever you just did to
do that. Could you create a supervised learning
algorithm for doing this? Sure. Right?
You would basically look for all the configurations
of your entire system every time the helicopter
was upright. And you would look for all the
examples where your helicopter was tipping
over or falling. And you would basically say,
OK, my engine speed was this much. My rotor
speed was this much.
And there are probably people here who fly
helicopters, so pardon me if I am completely
oversimplifying this problem here. However,
you could certainly label it that way and
say all these configurations of the helicopter
meant the helicopter was upright. All these
configurations of the helicopter meant the
helicopter was not upright.
That would be pretty expensive and difficult
data-- collect to do. Not sure how many people
want to volunteer for-- let's do all the ones
that are at faults. And lots of other applications
beyond that. So these are really useful, especially
in cases where-- what you're trying to model
is just extremely complex. And the other really
powerful thing is this tends to mimic human
behavior. And so they're very useful in those
type of applications.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain, shortly, what a
reward would look like?
VIJAY GADEPALLY: So a reward would just be--
it would be very similar until you get points.
So you have your algorithm that's basically
trying to maximize the number of points that
it receives, for example. And as you do--
it's very similar to what you or I would consider
a reward playing a video game, right?
Every time I get points, I do more of the
activities that make me get points. And it's
essentially the same concept over here. All
right. So with that, I will conclude only
20 minutes behind schedule. So I guess the
long story short is there's lots of exciting
research into AI and machine learning techniques
out here.
We did a one-hour view of this broad field
that research has dedicated about six to seven
decades of work to words, so my apologies
to anyone watching this or in the room whose
work I just jumped over. The key ingredients,
however-- and I think this is most important
to this group-- is I look at what are the
problems where AI has done really well.
These are some of the key ingredients-- data
availability, computing infrastructure, and
the domain expertise and algorithms. And I
think it's very exciting to see this group
over here, because we do have all of these
pieces coming together. So great things are
bound to happen.
There are, I think, large challenges in data
availability and readiness for AI, which is
what we're just going to scrape the edge off
during this class. And some of the computing
infrastructure is something that we'll be
talking to you about in a couple of minutes.
And if you're interested in some of the more
detailed look at any of these things, a number
of us actually wrote-- maybe I'm biased. I
think it's a great, great, great write-up.
But, no, I think it's useful. It has its places.
Obviously, a lot of material in here. But
we try to do our best job to at least cite
some of this really, really interesting work
that's going on in the field. So with that,
I'll pause for any additional questions, but
thank you very much for your attention.